so
will smith
slapped
chris rock
and
obviously a lot of people are talking
about it
um i guess we're talking about it now
too but here's the thing my first
reaction honestly when i saw this happen
i was
uh
you know
thought to myself hey these you know
that's what happens you talk smack if
you talk smack occasionally you're gonna
get smacked right that's what happens
and the reason i feel so i was i didn't
think much about it i don't know he's
got smack i kind of chuckled whatever
but then everyone started getting like
hype about it right
okay so
when you're in a seal platoon
occasionally someone's going to get
smacked right but you're on a
construction site occasionally someone's
going to get smacked i just i guess more
back in the day but still
when you're at your house
with your brother
someone's gonna get smacked right i mean
it occasionally happens things escalate
uh now
does this mean that i condone violence
right
a platoon scrap is not violence
you know what i'm saying like two high
school kids on the same football team
that
that get in each other's face and maybe
they get maybe maybe there's a takedown
happen maybe there's a couple slaps
i guess we could include that as
violence but i don't
i guess i condone that kind of violence
is that bad
no and it's for a specific reason okay
like you're talking about mutual like
accepted like but like two people
fighting that's different yeah like
walking up to you know there's a reason
though it first of all a platoon scrap
is not
actual violence it's a tension release
and it and it establishes
or maintains or keeps maintenance of the
pecking order now here's the thing mind
you
just like chimpanzees
right you know the chimpanzees the
physical power like the biggest
strongest chimpanzee he won't actually
maintain control of the
tribe
because eventually if he's an [ __ ]
the other two or three chimps that are a
little bit smaller will gang up on him
and put him out of power
it's the same thing in a seal platoon
you can't just go around beating
everyone up or you're going to catch a
beat down so there's a
there is times when oh there's going to
be a van fight right or the two platoon
guys are going to go out behind a mill
van and throw it down so that that
stuff's going to happen or occasionally
someone's going to get slapped up
for running their suck
and
so it's a thing things occasionally get
physical and by the way a slap isn't
like a crazy
thing a slap doesn't really damage right
a slap doesn't really leave damage
it's more humiliating than anything else
right it's a it's a humiliation thing
it's a statement but it's not to knock
someone out if i want to fight you i'm
not going to slap you i'm going to i'm
going to punch you in the face right a
closed fist is totally different
if i close my fist and punch you in the
face i'm trying to hurt you
now listen
don't get me wrong if someone slaps you
you're kind of authorized to retaliate
you could say it's on right but but tell
me i'm wrong here
whoever slapped you just gave you a
warning that you're out of line
they're giving you an option to assess
your behavior and stand down
i've slapped people before and had them
stand down
so
they might be right
right when you if you're getting slapped
by someone and you go oh damn like i
didn't realize echo was so
sensitive about this thing and i went
too far and i assassinated
i crossed the line
now if you punched me it's on right
there's really no choice right you're if
you
uh are you agree in agreement that
there's a difference yes you punt
somebody you have effectively started a
fight it's a fight if you slap someone
you've really checked them you pot you
need to be ready to fight because it's
totally acceptable that if you get
slapped you can pau you you're fighting
yeah but there is a difference between
closed fist punch and a slap to the face
so
you might have deserved the slap now did
chris rock
deserve to get slapped
in my opinion
no
he's a comedian bro he's a comedian he's
roasting people that's what he does for
a living by the way he's sitting there
he's going to roast anyone in that that
comes to that thing yeah is a viable
option to get roasted and has always
been like that by the way always been
like that
and by the way
will smith is a famous and successful
actor it's not like he's picking on you
ever heard that thing about punching up
yeah have you ever heard this it's okay
to punch up but it's not okay to punch
down so you're not allowed to make fun
of and this is i'm i actually mean this
sincerely
you're not a lot you shouldn't be making
fun of someone that is in a less
powerful position than you right you
shouldn't be making fun of you know the
the if you're if you're out for dinner
and you're a wealthy person and there's
a waiter
yeah and you start
you know belittling the waiter
you might get slapped
because you're you're you're punching
down
but
it's generally more okay for someone to
take shots at someone that's above them
and you and why is that well because the
person's in a position of power they can
kind of shrug it off so this room by the
way is filled with all people that are
all rich and all famous including will
smith and including his wife
she's an act
actress too
you know so she's famous
but
will will smith slap him upside the head
so why is that why did that happen
and
i didn't really know i don't know much
about celebrity people about hollywood
right i don't know much about this scene
but when i saw that i saw the replay
right
because i'm not obviously sitting around
watching watching these oscars so i see
the replay and i thought immediately i
thought to myself he's got some issues
right and yet specifically probably has
some issues with his wife i don't know
anything about this dude
but i look and they play in the replay
you could see he was like will smith was
laughing
that's a funny joke he looked at his
wife she was pissed then he gets up
and and
smacks uh
chris rock
and
[Music]
were you gonna say something nope okay
you're listening okay so well if i'm
wrong please tell me if i'm wrong
because i'm just kind of i don't know
everything about this i don't even know
about these people right so there's a
bunch of different
separate elements that make up this
whole incident well here's the thing
after i said to myself there's something
wrong with this dude there's something
wrong with their relationship it turns
out i was 100 right
i was 100 right i found out that his
wife that will smith's wife
she's
and i don't know the details but 100
she's been involved with other dudes
right
which is
apparently they split up for a while or
or they were together or whatever but
she was out with
other dudes and and i read a little
section
she got interviewed about it and said
she got it yeah what's that they both
did okay
yeah they totally went public with that
part well check this out she said she
got quote entangled
with some other dude and then this other
dude writes a rap song about being
entangled with her like as if what that
actually means yes sir
so you got all this stuff eaten at will
smith
right i mean this is
eating at him now why
i always thought to me in my opinion i
didn't know anything about will smith
all i know is what i see you know on the
front lines of media right yeah this is
the fresh
prince of bel air right he just seemed
like a nice square away guy
that's that's what kind of what i was as
soon as i didn't know about all this
other stuff i know he had this crazy
relationship with his wife she's out
being with other guys and stuff that's
got to drive him crazy right he's
frustrated
and then it's like they got
they got money going to scientology and
start uncovering this kind of stuff if
he gets wild real quick so he's got all
kinds of stuff going on he's got issues
and this is like a road rage incident
right or a person or a person that
swears at the cashier in the grocery
store right yeah or a person that starts
a fight in the bar
they're not mad at the cashier they're
not mad at the person that cut them off
they're not mad at the person they bump
into in a bar they're having a bad day
or they're having a in will smith case
he's having a couple bad years right yes
so they're gonna lash out
and it's not good it it's weak it shows
insecurity i mean you're super insecure
if you got a lash out like this
it reveals a lack of
[Music]
control
and it's just not strong behavior
because the strong person's not gonna
get bothered by
this kind of thing right it's a joke
right you can't let it and this goes for
her too
yeah right is there anything better to
do if i go echo you know uh you wish you
had some hair
is there any better response than for
you to say i wish i did too hahaha we
all laugh right yeah or for you to be
like hey don't make fun of my hair bro
like all day long it's not a laughing
match in fact you gave you gave one of
the best responses i've ever seen on
social media and i'm being totally
serious one of the best responses
somebody on social media i posted about
a podcast and somebody wrote somebody
wrote
somebody wrote i don't know why the
other guy echoing quotes even talks he's
got nothing to offer he doesn't bring
anything to the table and we i wish he
would just be quiet and let jocko talk
and you responded
and you responded and you said honestly
i think that's a pretty fair assessment
and i was like dude echo just won the
internet
that's how you respond when someone's
trying to
you know trying to get in you know
trying to get their little mark in on
you
so
when you go in the other direction and
you get super defensive
it's it's showing that it's bothering
you it's showing you that
you
are are insecure about the situation
yeah it seems that way
if you're a strong man right
you're kind of in an unassailable
unassailable position you you people can
say things you know it's not gonna
really bother you when you're a weak
person or you're you feel like you're in
a weak situation
you feel exposed and you feel like you
got to lash out but there's nothing
especially when someone just talks to
you nothing's going to someone that's a
a strong powerful human they don't get
bothered when someone chirp chirps at
them it just rolls off their back
whatever man
but if you do get bothered then there's
something wrong there's some kind of
insecurity there
which is exactly what i think this
revealed will will smith is probably
insecure about his position that he he
is in with his wife which is a bummer
man like i said he seems like a nice guy
um and he acted out in a way
that
that that makes him look like that look
could you say look he dishonored my wife
that's what it was essentially all about
there was there was there was there's
the you could go the path of look this
guy dishonored my wife
hey if someone touches your wife
cool you're cleared hot right
um
if somebody does something that's like
radically offensive to her like maybe
they say something that's
just off the top ropes offensive
and you feel like you gotta
you feel like you gotta crush somebody
cool yeah go you know go
um
but if someone makes a joke about her
yes
bro it's kind of cut and dry with that
part okay i didn't know it was cut and
dry yes it's because here's like is it
kind of cut and drug because it's not
yeah nothing's really okay yeah but okay
so you're saying disrespect yeah if
someone disrespects your wife in front
of people all this stuff which which
that that's kind of the the two issues
right that people are either for this
whole incident or against the incident
like for will smith or you know a guy a
guy standing up for his wife
you know beautiful right people think or
it's like yeah a guy can't take a joke
or a girl can't take a joke whatever
right which i think it's bro what is it
he's not standing up for his wife
brother that was a joke from a comedian
about a feature of of jada pinkett smith
she has alopecia which is the same as
it's balding that's all it is it's not
like
cancer so she had to say shave her head
or nothing it's literally only for looks
that's what it is the hair losing okay
cool not to say it's awesome i'm not
saying that but he made a joke he didn't
disrespect the wife disrespect you can
disrespect
someone's wife to me anyway this much
and catch a beat down in front of you in
a very small amount yes that wasn't that
was making a joke that was like a roast
like that's that's part of the game that
they're all in that's the word yeah like
look disrespecting is the kind where
it's not a joke where it's like like oh
like i don't know if you would have said
something like hey you know you kind of
deserve that or something something
that's not a joke something that's
disrespectful
now
now you go into the realm of like okay
well will smith and jada pinkett smith
that's who really couldn't take the joke
this is the girl yeah well smith has
just suffered the consequences of the
situation poor guy because of what you
said this is what it seems i probably
can't read his mind i don't know but
this is what it looked like
where yeah he's laughing and then jade
picking smith of course she's not
laughing she's rolling her eyes and then
it kind of cuts and then all of a sudden
will smith's mad and going up on the
stage all costing the freaking host of
the freaking
awards show right
and
um but yeah it's like a roast everyone
gets roasted for worse stuff than that
by the way
not just for balding like guys are
balding all day every day yeah and guess
what they get teased about their bald
head every single day all day and then
all of a sudden become sensitive about
that
all of a sudden it's this big
disrespectful freaking attacking
someone's wife and then this hero
standing up for him no bro you guys
couldn't take a joke because you guys
are all sensitive and weak that's what
it was in front of everybody the
opposite yeah of hey this guy is tough
and great because he's standing up for
his wife actually this guy is weak
because he couldn't take it didn't you
take a joke and then he stands up to
chris rock by the way what if it was
another who's a tough comedian dude what
about joe rogan let's go let's just go
let's go joe roger do you think wilson's
going to stand up to jordan no no no
he's going to take the beating from jada
pinkett smith that's what meeting he's
going to take he stood up to
chris rock and what's chris rock going
to do nothing
not going to do nothing yeah we'll spend
no seconds though
well as far as chris rock goes
my thoughts on chris rock first of all
this this dude got caught completely off
guard completely and utter utterly off
guard
don't ever ever ever
let someone walk at you like that in any
situation with your hands down and don't
and and don't lose control of distance
right
don't let someone enter your space
without getting your hands your feet and
your body into a fighting position now
look this doesn't mean that you square
off does that mean you put your dukes up
yeah but you raise your hand you know
you've seen this before like this is
what we teach in jiu jitsu someone's
someone starts approaching you you put
your hands up kind of like the hey i
don't want i don't want your problem but
now you're protecting your face and
you're ready to do something you switch
your stance from being square which you
know your square stance where you're
just
facing completely forward you switch you
know you drop a foot back and you put
your hands up and that's kind of looks
like you're backing away which you are
because you're creating some distance so
you don't
you don't let anyone ever walk at you
without getting yourself in a position
where you're ready to fight now listen
the dude had good reason
a good excuse for this no excuses but
his excuses bro he's at the oscars he's
talking to a world famous guy that's
about to win an academy award you know a
guy that's worth hundreds of millions of
dollars and this guy's a known this guy
that's saying stuff chris rock is a
known actual comedian and the standard
protocol at these things is people get
roasted
so
here's the deal
lesson learned for everybody yes no
matter what the situation someone starts
walking at you
you get your hands up you get ready to
defend yourself and that's what you do
and by the way will smith actually ends
up kind of looking weak too because he
sucker punched the dude and he and chris
rock barely i i actually checked he
takes after he gets hit he takes like a
half a step back and it's no factor to
him other than it's it's humiliating
right
so then once he got slapped
he made a choice
he actually made a choice and he kind of
read it the way that i was talking about
earlier
he wasn't assaulted oh look people like
he got assaulted he didn't get punched
in the face he didn't get knocked out he
didn't he got slapped and he read it as
a
warning that he had crossed the line and
like i said the slap didn't even phase
him it was a weak slap like he he he
chuckled immediately he was laughing
yeah they made a joke
well that took him a second but it
barely moved him he and then he kind of
laughed it off
and you could see chris rock was totally
like
shocked and surprised and he didn't
really know what to do so he lightened
the mood he tried to make a joke he said
will smith will smith just smacked the
[ __ ] out of me he's trying to
de-escalate right trying to de-escalate
good for him you know he's trying to
he's a professional
he's trying to de-escalate and sure this
might be people right now like you got
to be kidding me if you get stopped well
he's trying to maintain this whole
freaking big deal what's he supposed to
do we're gonna we're gonna get a fight
right now we're gonna get a brawl he
decided not to do that and he decided
that he decided probably almost
instantly that this guy's got freaking
issues like this guy you know it's like
when you're driving your car and
somebody cuts you off and they start
going crazy like you know what this guy
has issues
this guy's having a worse day than i am
and chris rock realized real quick hey
will smith's having a worse life than me
by a long shot he might be rich he might
be famous he might be a movie star he
might be getting an academy award but
he's has a worse life than me he's
hooked up with a crazy woman apparently
they're in weird cultish activities with
scientology like this is a nightmare and
so chris rock
completely surprised tries to make out
and then will smith starts yelling dude
yeah and swearing and and chris rock's
like it was a joke dude that's literally
what he says it was a joke dude
and and then
he yells again keep became my wife's
name how do you [ __ ] like you can
tell not okay he's this guy's not he's
not healthy right this guy's not okay um
and then chris rock
again you gotta give him some credit he
totally detached he didn't lose his
temper
uh he just acted like a he actually act
like a man right now look
is there part of me that if he would
have like ducked and delivered like a
left hook and knocked this dude out that
would have been that would have been
that was kind of epic right yes sir but
he didn't do that no because he already
failed nine different ways by letting
this dude get up and get close to him so
he already screwed up
but i'm talking after it happened what
was his reaction what was he gonna do
like run after him and have people hold
him back and start that whole thing now
that he would have really looked stupid
so
he was caught off guard
by this happening so bad that it took
him a couple seconds to realize and once
he realized the position he was in this
is where this where i'll give him credit
once he realized the situation he was in
he didn't make it worse yeah yeah he
salvaged it to the best of his ability
and by the way you know
he had to put his ego in check to do
that right
he he had to put his ego in check to do
that to stand there and be like hey
everybody that guy's got issues
and i don't i'm actually i'm actually a
grown ass man that is secure in myself
and i'm not going to react to this idiot
that's losing his mind over his wife
that
obviously has issues
so he de-escalated now if he wanted to
if he gets fired up now dude he could
rip this guy apart
i mean verbally like he could go he
could make a youtube video that would
get a hundred million views of him just
bashing this guy making fun of him hey
this guy slapped me i didn't even feel
it right oh hey wait a minute he could
just go off he could
pull their whole freaking weird
relationship this open relationship the
fact that this girl's been running
around with other guys the fact that
they're in a weird cult that you know
like all this crazy he could just rip
them up but he could rip him apart he
could rip her apart
he could do that
he could do that he could shred him like
in a in a youtube video but i think
actually the power move
i think the power move would be to say
hey listen
will smith
is clearly not happy he's clearly having
a tough time in his life
uh
i i never would mean to hurt anybody's
feelings if i knew it was going to
affect him so deeply i i wish him the
best i hope he heals up i hope he i hope
everything works out
that would be kind and chris rock
doesn't have much anything to prove bro
he's a legit guy he's a self-made guy
his mom was a schoolteacher and his dad
was a truck driver
he's one of eight kids from brooklyn
right and he's one of the most famous
comedians of all time
and he's one of the most famous
comedians of all time
so he doesn't have anything to prove
but you know once he got smacked um
he already looked kind of dumb letting
it happen getting all nuts afterwards
like i said would have made him probably
look even dumber he wasn't even hurt he
wasn't even phased
so
like i said he should not let it happen
um don't let people get in your face
like that don't get emotional you know
if and
and don't let don't let people talking
smack
affect you emotionally like that it's
just embarrassing
and imagine if if will smith if he would
have done that and he would have gone up
to the microphone late late you know
when he got his award
and he would have said something then
something that he could have thought
through and said something powerful you
know if he said listen you know my wife
has this disease and it can be really
hard especially in this industry and you
know to me the most the reason you know
i love my wife is because of who's you
know whatever like he could he could
have really
risen above it and come across like a
really uh powerful good dude
but unfortunately lost his temper
and
and just caused this whole scene so what
can we learn from it um
keep calm
people are going to talk smack
that's what's going to happen in life
don't get spun up if you're getting mad
it's probably because you're insecure or
they're striking at some level of truth
so be careful of that and remember that
if you're the one that's talking smack
you don't know what the other person's
going through you know what kind of day
they've had and if you run your mouth
you might get smacked so don't be
surprised if you're running your suck if
someone gets up and slaps you in the
face
so
and that means don't let people
get into your personal space without
getting into some kind of a defensive
posture
that's what i got those are some
thoughts i i'm sure i'm not right i'm
sure i'm not wrong i'm sure there's some
things that i don't know about the
situation because i don't know about
these freaking weird hollywood
characters
that
who despite their fame and their money
and their luck and their entourages and
their position of elevation in our
culture
they're still just human beings
and we human beings are still just
animals
so try not to act like one
stay safe everyone out there and do me a
favor
be nice to each other
but wait though
so wait so what's the so there's no
consensus then for you like like was it
right was it wrong there's 40 there's
probably 114
critique points where this could have
gone in different directions yeah so
it's not like
right or wrong there's a bunch of right
and right or wrong decisions that are
made the whole way right you're so right
because you started this thing this
thing when you're saying um
uh you gotta expect okay so
okay there's two the two sides right
where it's like okay you got a comedian
making a joke right so people
when you make jokes about someone
especially if you make a joke about a
girl like a like a roast joke to a girl
in front of her husband
just think just think about that
regardless of where it was oscars no
oscars whatever you're you're making a
joke about a girl roasting a girl a
female in front of her husband
if you were to take a multiple true or
false a and b question do would you
expect to get slapped by the husband or
would you not expect to get slapped by
the husband bro half of us would say yes
you should be more than half put they're
both right you know like they to put it
this way eat any answer is not
surprising right if i roast a girl on
the street no a lot of times i get it
where it's like comedians it's a joke
and it's in a setting with a joke or
whatever by the rule doesn't change but
actually check this out bro you and
sarah charles go to the comedy club
the comedy club whatever it's called in
la jolla yeah and you're sitting three
rows back you're not in the front row
and the dude looks out there he sees
sarah charles and she's like well you
know she insults her
or sorry
he the comedian insults her yeah
so if he right you're at a clear like a
literal comedy show perfect yeah that's
actually a good question so i'm at a
comedy show right
and a comedian makes it depends it
depends on the joke so okay so and even
that that is a bunch of different parts
so what
i mean dude there's
like the
level of joke insult would have to be
insane insane for me to get me to stand
up and smack it dude 100 so by the way i
wouldn't slap him yeah he would have to
say something where i'm attacking him to
kill him
i would say to answer your question if
put it this way the worst realistic
scenario is like that he'd say something
about sarah that she's insecure about
that really hurt her feelings
but that doesn't warrant me going and
trying to beat up the comedian yeah it
doesn't work me that at all yeah
but first of all like
and this is just my side of the thing
not the comedian side the comedian side
you gotta expect that kind of stuff you
start roasting girls and the husband
comes and smacks you bro you got to be
ready for that
100
but i'm not the comedian in this
scenario i'm i'm the guy okay there's a
difference between how you feel and then
how you behave i've said that before
where yeah you're gonna offend me what's
the grown-up thing to do for real like i
understand defending your wife and
someone's attacking your wife and
standing up for your wife like oh i
understand that but at a comedian shell
yeah and a guy makes a joke even if it's
a shitty joke yeah and it hurts your
wife's feelings bro that's different
yeah right you don't like the show we'll
just leave yeah yeah i'll be like hey
you want to leave i get it you know and
you just leave that's not you're not
not def you're not failing to defend her
honor just because she got offended by
the joke yeah but that's a whole
different thing you know what's
interesting about this is let's say
uh
you know the let's say i was the
comedian yeah right and i'm 230 pounds
and i'm up there and i start ragging
there's some guy that's
70 pounds or whatever 150 pounds and
he's a nerd and he doesn't train and he
and i started
right
he knows that he can't fight against me
right and that's real obvious right but
here's the thing
let's say
the roles are reversed i'm in the crowd
there's a 150 pound nerd
comedian up there i'm there with my wife
and he starts talking he starts
insulting my wife
i actually don't have the
riffs
or the what's it called like the shtick
to talk smack back he's a professional
[ __ ] talker
so if i engage with him i'm actually
gonna lose he's gonna make me look even
stupider yeah he's gonna go oh you can't
put a center is that your best comeback
i mean he's got all these things ready
so it's an uneven fight so it's kind of
an uneven fight for chris rock they said
that he told that joke during rehearsals
and no one everyone was like laughing
and thought it was funny they were
laughing even during the thing yeah
everyone left so so
you have an unevenness
of you've got someone with a microphone
and you've got the person in the crowd
and you've prepared to insult them
and you probably have some comebacks
ready well just because that's what you
do yeah so that's why i'm saying even to
you know if if
even if you're gonna yell something back
you're you're engaging in combat that
you're gonna lose that's my point yeah
if you if you're like don't talk about
my wife like that you know
what he's going to say to you next is
going to destroy you
and her right yep it's going to so what
you're best to do is laugh
and look if she's totally insulted cool
well we'll walk out and even as you walk
out expect to get stabbed with some
shots in the back because that's exactly
what he's gonna make fun of you oh she
must be real insecure about that i can
tell why you know what i mean like it's
coming it's gonna happen
so
it's best to keep control over your
emotions
it's best not to give people the
satisfaction of me you know if they can
see it on your face
i mean they're common in hot that's one
thing you learn in the seal teams right
if you
show that you're
if that that's whatever they're saying
to you bothers you they're they're
coming at it so don't let that happen
man
so there's another theory too about the
will smith
uh chris rock thing so this i think in
2016 chris rock was hosting again and he
was talking trash about jada pinkett
smith he made a joke about her roast
dinner again she wasn't there i think
that was the time they're boycotting it
maybe i don't know i forget
so japanese smith not there not at the
oscars so they're like um something
about uh chris rock's jokes had some
said something like this where he said
oh yeah jada pinkett uh was like yeah
i'm not coming to the oscars or whatever
i declined to come to the oscars and
then he said um
hey you can't decline to come to oscars
that's like me declining to go into
rihanna's panties i was never invited in
the first place
that was the joke
so there was that went on so he was
roasting her since 2016. so maybe will
smith because he said keep my wife's
name out of your mouth maybe that had
something to do with it some say maybe
it was boiling boiling over yep and
again if you're will smith
bro
man
you you got you got to let this stuff
like run off your back he's a comedian
yeah he's a comedian
and it's just going to be awkward now
you know what it kind of felt like too
when you watch it because like he ran he
went up there smacked a little guy
around yeah and just walked back turned
his back to him and walked back all
casually and almost kind of proud you
know what it really came off and smelled
like like like entitlement
like i'm will smith i can just roll up
and smack guys are smaller than me
weaker than me because they get salty
about their jokes and just walk back to
my seat it was super entitlement so you
were a little pissed off about that
whole scene huh it was
it was pretty whack it was a bad luck
for sure um and
i wasn't pissed off but i was i was more
like you can see the violations on both
sides because comedians will do that too
sometimes where they'll just make jokes
and they're out there this little guy
like you know this guy's not prepared
physically for this thing
and
i i learned this when i first moved to
here to san diego where in hawaii if you
talk trash to somebody you just gotta be
hundred percent ready just
and this is not a like there is no
exception like
you got to be ready for that kind of
stuff so in
san diego i moved to san diego and i get
it it's a little bit more of an upscale
club or
you know a little bit more entitled folk
might frequent so
man the way they would talk to me was
like bruh it was baffling it was
confusing to me but then you can see
there in their eyes they're like brah
this guy's not ready for any physical
confrontation and that's how some
comedians can be yeah so i was a little
bit salty with that too i was like oh
chris rock you know you you know brother
man brought it brought it back down to
the streets and bro you weren't ready
for it right even though he did handle
it good and it wasn't even that hard
like well you know what it did when he
swung he kind of almost like he was
almost trying to dodge it right at the
last minute so i don't think he
connected as hard as it it could have
weak weak behavior
on both on all sides right you got to be
careful with that good stuff
right on anyways i guess we'll add our
freaking stupid uh opinions to this
whole freaking dumbass situation
uh don't put these people on a pedestal
they don't deserve it stay calm out
there be nice to each other that's what
i got we'll catch y'all later